as an actor to walk onto a set where you
have a depth and height and shape and
everything is authentic it just creates
realism for us to play around in
The Silo is incredibly cinematic it's a
new world told in a completely new way
this is as big as any feature film the
number of sets we have is 70 plus when
we designed the silo we decided to make
all the building blocks circular all the
Alleyways the stairways everything has
this rounded element to it the sets are
incredibly moving they are the Cathedral
of the whole story
everything is magical it's so detailed
it's so beautiful the world is so well
realized life in The Silo replicates a
lot of things we're used to in our world
from Living Spaces to factories to Farms
it's a complete World built mile down
into the Earth
[Music]
the experience of watching the world of
The Silo come to life absolutely blew me
away the scope of The Silo was even
bigger than more awe-inspiring than I
imagined
everything is used everything is
recycled whether they are phones or
watches or little Pez dispenser it's so
detailed it's so stunning
gift to be able to get lost in this
world in a way that feels completely
real
creating the world of The Silo we wanted
it to feel like nothing we've seen
anywhere else
[Music]